- Hello my name is Sharon Mig,
and I come from a hard life,
but I'm grateful today.
I've been in the streets
since I was 13 years old.
I've been molested by
blue van with 18 guys
took me in a alley and I thought
they was going to kill me
but by the grace of God, I lived.
Not only that, car
accident I had 72 stitches
through my face, and
I still got a complex.
Glass went in my eye, I lost my eyesight,
and it's hard out here.
I'm living in a tent.
My family really they don't
understand, but I don't wanna
live with them. I got a
niece she's 12 years old
do you know my name is
the only name she can say
she's autistic, she'll live just like me.
And I'm grateful, I've met good people
and I've met bad people.
I have a tent.
I keep hi-jinks and yes, I drink and stuff
and I give anybody anything
you ain't gotta steal from me.
And that hurts my feelings.
And to be honest with you
I'm tired of being in the streets.
I'm so tired.
I can't see out of this side behind that.
And these scars and stuff
really, really bother me.
Sometimes I'd be willing
to give up, but I do pray.
Last few days, I done lost
some close friends of mine.
And I'm just seeing how they
going and any day it can be me
and I really want to change my life.
I just don't know how.
(Sharon giggling)
Man, I'm just emotional right now.
I just lost my mother.
And she, you know, she, she tried to make
up for what I went through with her.
She bought me a mother and daughter ring
both our birth signs and
mother and daughter on it.
I pawned to the dope man.
She bought me a gold chain with a heart.
I pawned that to the dope man.
She asked me, she said,
baby, where your stuff?
I said at home, she never asked me again.
It took me eleven years
to tell my mother the truth what I did.
And she said, Sharon, I
forgave you a long time ago.
She said, I know things
you think, I don't know.
She said, now you got to forgive yourself.
I had an attitude till I
understand what she said.
I got to stop blaming the
world because I'm grown now.
I can make my own choice.
I sabotage myself, you know, kids love me.
I don't have any children.
And my feelings was hurt.
I couldn't hold them.
And I see women with babies
and I don't understand
why they don't love them.
But guess what?
Kids everywhere love me.
And I'm grateful for that too.
Couple of them ran away to
my friend who is a dope man.
Yeah. He sent them to me
because he knew I would take care of them.
First one she told everybody she was 18
but she told me she was 15 in foster care.
I let her stay with me a couple of days.
And I called the people
to come and get her.
She ran away again with
another, the third time another
and all of a sudden I'm
coming up at the apartment.
I was living in with a friend
and police officer went up only.
It was the Sergeant.
And I said, Oh Lord, he got out the car.
He said Sharon Mig?
And I was on parole. I
knew I had a warrant.
He said, I know they call you Brendan.
He said, I know you on parole.
He said that ain't what I came for.
He said, there's some special
about you, because foster
care want to help you.
And I'm looking, he said,
miss Meeks, if I got
gotta go in my pockets and pay
for you to go in the program.
I would, he said,
because, you got to give.
And it scared me. I run
away from good things.
I run all the time.
I'm sitting up there and a
little boys in front of me
everybody's saying green.
I said, well, they said,
look in front of you.
When I looked, it was like,
he couldn't have been no more
than six or seven little Mexican boy.
When I made eye contact, he said, hi.
I said, hi. He said, I love you.
And when he started walking to me
his mother called him, the
daddy said, leave him alone.
And baby walked up and
grabbed my hand, stood up.
Mann church people came out of everywhere.
It's a thousand people on this street.
Why me?
That baby wouldn't let my hand go.
People said that, god bless me.
If I need help, I can
call this place again.
The baby said, please
call us if you need it.
I said, okay, I'm a go.
He said, please get off this corner.
I was on St.Junior and I
was selling weed and stuff.
I bent down, gave him a hug and I left.
But when I went to my motel,
I ate a piece of chicken
picked up a pipe and hit it.
30 minutes later, I cried myself to sleep.
Everywhere I go, kids love me.
I love them, animals love me.
But half the time, I don't
feel like I'm worthy.
And I know I should be strong
but I just fall because,
my daddy didn't want me.
My mother mistreated me,
but she tried to make up.
But thank God my brothers and
them, love me, I thank God
for Mark, but allow me to tell my story.
And I'm not ashamed of
it. I was at one time.
And like my mother said, I, I
like, I got to forgive myself
and stop blaming the
world cause I'm grown.
And I made my own choices.
It's hard being out here.
They goin in people's tent.
They molested, three weeks ago.
They molested a 16 year old little boy.
Finally, somebody called by
the time the police got there
when they bought that
baby out of that tent
he was bloody from head to toe.
They looked at that camera
Men. So many guys went in that tent
and molested this little boy.
And they called themselves
gang members and stuff.
16 years old.
And one ni**a excuse my language.
One guy had the nerve to
say, well, he out here.
he put himself in that position.
I said, he's 16. He probably ran away.
Probably just getting
the high to get away.
That don't mean he deserved at that.
They got so much going
on out here, so much.
The closest friends is
the ones who will get you.
(car engine roaring)
I called them my friends knowing
they can't be my friends.
See you can only do to
me what I allow you.
And now I gotta start
treating myself right.
And eventually I will.
But I'm 64 years old.
I'm telling you I've been in
the streets since I was 13.
And I thank God I'm living.
I'm just saying.
If your story is half is mine.
Don't do yourself. Don't
think, you nothing.
Pray on it. Put your head up
because you ain't hurting them.
You hurting yourself
There are many times I laid
in that tent and I cried.
(Sharon talking while crying)
You have no idea how tired I am.
I just don't know how to change.
I've been, I've been
doing this since I was 13
and I don't
I want to change so bad.
People done try to help me
put me in hotels and stuff.
I don't go. Like I said, I
didn't think I was worthy.
Even though I know I am.
And even though I don't know how
I gotta put more strength
in it, I'm alright.
Like I say, you got to forgive yourself.
You don't know how many
times I've been raped.
Beat up, jumped on.
Food stamp cards taken.
People say grans
I would call the police.
I said, no, I go and get
another card, whatever.
But I thank God. I'm still living.
November, before our people was given away
back packs and stuff I went there.
And this lady walked up to me.
She was a white woman.
She said, what's your name?
And I told her, she
said, can I talk to you?
I said, yeah.
She said, you got a beautiful smile
but I see so much sadness in your eyes.
I said, you would be too.
We've been in the streets, homeless.
And you can't get no help.
And she asked me, could
she see how I lived?
So I showed her my tent, I took
pictures and did everything.
And I started crying together.
The next day my nephew ran up
there and said, auntie greener
I saw you on TV. I said TV.
They said you was on channel four news.
And you, they said (engine
roaring), man, you cry.
When you put it down. I
said, the news, they said
you didn't know you was on the news
I said no.
And he said, you ought to sue her.
I said sue her.
For what?
Two months later I got my SSI.
People start wanting to help me.
And if it wasn't for that
woman, put me on the channel
Four news, nobody would've
reached out and touched me.
And you talkin bout "sue her"?
Tell me she is the
reason I'm in a position
that I'm moving up now and want to change.
Y'all better think about what
y'all say and do with good
people come in your life.
See they came in mind and I sabotaged it
because I didn't think I was
worthy to do nothing good.
Like that police officer, that sheriffs
they want to pay to put me in a program.
Cause he said, I got to give.
And it's something special about me, man.
I never dreamed that would happen to me.
So don't listen to damness,
because it'll only dig you deeper.
I walk down the same street,
fall in the same hole.
Now I'm gonna walk around that hole
because I'm tired of falling
I don't know who she is.
I ain't seen her since
but I wanna thank God
for meeting that woman.
I want to thank God for meeting Mark.
My mother's gone now
and I want to thank God for catching on.
When she said, forgive
yourself, can't blame the world.
Better choice. And I choose to do better.
I don't know how, but imma do it.
And I'm not ashamed
of the things that happened
to me because it happened.
And it made me stronger.
Very strong.
I'm coming out at that tent y'all.
- [Sharon] I'm coming out that tent
You can believe that.
Oh, and I've gonna have
operation on my eye
You know I'm blind in this eye
because glass went through
here in that car accident
but it hit my nerve
and they gone do surgery.
I said, they gotta have
three, but they guarantee me.
I see again.
That's going to be so beautiful.
I wear shades all the time.
I tell you all this I'm ashamed of
but guess what? I'm living.
And at 64, I look good.
- [Man] Yes you do.
Thank you very much.
You are too.
That was so sweet.
That was beautiful.